a
washington journal continues
fiona hill joins us now she's a former
senior staffer on the trump
administration national security council
she span viewers likely to remember her
from her testimony before congress
during the first impeachment of the
former president she's also the author
of the new book there's nothing for you
here finding opportunity in the 21st
century uh fiona hill take us back to
november 21st of 2019 to that
impeachment testimony you spent a good
time at the start of that testimony
talking about your journey to the u.s
and how you became an american by choice
why did you think that was an important
story to tell at the outset of that
hearing
well really john it was a reaction to
what has happened behind closed doors um
a month or so earlier i mean practically
actually exactly two
uh years ago this month um october 14th
of 2019 when i'd been called into closed
door hearings to give a deposition in
advance of
the actual public testimony all of those
uh depositions were led to release to
the public
but in the time that i was you know
there for actually 10 hours and being
questioned by members of congress
it wasn't just the issues that they were
raising uh that i later talked about in
the testimony that caught my attention
it was the way that um
excuse me i and um
the other fact witnesses who'd been
called up were being accused of all
kinds of things our credibility was
being uh put into question our
patriotism you know our objectivity you
know people were you know essentially
accusing us of as the president and
others said publicly of being deep state
coup plotters
suggesting that we were part of some
nefarious grouping of
uh bureaucrats unelected bureaucrats who
were somehow out there taking advantage
of the public and was alienated from the
rest of america i mean there were some
ridiculous things being said about us
including online and just the whole way
that the questioning was going
and as an immigrant as somebody came to
the united states in 1989 from the uk
i was also someone who came from
anything but um an elite or privileged
background i started to get very
disturbed about you know where the
direction of this was going
and so when it came to the public
testimony
i decided for the first time ever in my
career to explain who i was um in a
larger context i mean who i was as a
person where i'd come from why i was in
the united states and there'd been quite
a lot of attacks on some of my other
colleagues lieutenant colonel binman for
example who would come as a child from
what was then the soviet union um you
know in search of a better life
ambassador maria jovanovic our
ambassador to ukraine who had been
kicked out of her job and it would also
come from the former eastern bloc
uh family had come as immigrants and as
a child and there were so many people
that i'd served within the government
who came from very humble origins who'd
worked their way up in their careers
maybe by joining the military or you
know by basically wanting to do public
service after visiting their
congressman's office during a high
school trip or people like myself
immigrants many of whom had come from
war-torn societies who wanted to give
something back to the united states so i
wanted to begin my testimony by saying
who i was why i'd come to america why i
was so proud to be an american citizen a
citizen who'd taken an oath to the
country as i said an american by choice
like so many of the people i served
beside to try to put to rest this idea
that we were part of some bizarre
strange plot against the country that we
all loved and wanted to serve and in in
the wake of your testimony plenty of
coverage of you and and your story
you recall in the book one of your one
of the news articles called you the
improbable fiona hill
the financial times piece from a few
months later what about you is
improbable
well i mean for many people in the
united states it's always an improbable
journey to come from the bottom one
percent of society to the very top and i
mean that's part of our political
problems that are reflected in you know
your programming that people at the
bottom don't see themselves and i mean
but the socio-economic and also the
political run you know people in
far-flung places in the united states
you know with humble backgrounds that
were just kind of struggling on a
day-to-day basis don't see
themselves reflected at the very top in
any part of uh society in politics in uh
major business in education
you know often you know more likely than
not they might see themselves reflected
in the celebrities somebody who's also
had a kind of hard scrabble background
news kind of made it uh big in some way
and you know for me
i started off life in a coal mining town
in north of england one very similar to
anywhere in the kind of lehigh valley in
pennsylvania or parts of you know west
virginia or ohio any kind of coal
country in the united states i'm from a
long generation multi-generation of coal
miners all the men in my family were
coal miners on my dad's side on my
mother's side they worked in factories
or in shipyards and my granddad and my
mom's side worked in the sewers he was a
work for the local county council you
know the local government inspecting
sewers you know for example my family
were not upwardly mobile in fact you
know as my dad said most of us spent our
time working underground and when i was
born all the coal mines were closing and
in the entire period of my childhood the
whole economy was disappearing around us
and so it was very improbable that i
would you know basically get anywhere in
life in terms of getting an education or
even getting a good job and the title of
the book there's nothing for you here is
what my dad said to me as i was leaving
school in 1984 against the backdrop of a
massive unemployment crisis that if i
wanted to get any kind of education if i
wanted to get any kind of job and we
weren't envisaging anything like this i
mean who would have thought when my dad
was talking to me that i'd end up being
a national security expert and working
in the white house
he was basically saying there's nothing
for you here you're going to have to you
know basically go out there and find
something else especially as a girl at
that point because you know for women
the unemployment rate was even higher
and there were really very few jobs in
my hometown
if you want to help with us until 10 a.m
eastern taking your phone calls as we
talk about
her new book there's nothing for you
here finding opportunity in the 21st
century let me give the phone numbers
and you can go ahead and start calling
in republicans 202 748 8001 democrats
202 748 8 000
independence 202 748 8002 you talk about
your journey
and education that took you uh to the
white house national security council
director for russia issues there uh and
uh you write about uh your concerns
about russia uh and parallels that you
perhaps see in the world right now this
is what you write the example of modern
russia which i've spent most of my
career closely studying offers a
cautionary tale for the united states at
this juncture russia is america's ghost
of christmas future a harbinger of
things to come if we can't adjust course
and heal our political polarization how
is it the ghost of our christmas future
well look what we saw in russia in the
period in which i started to study it so
i started learning russia in 1984
against the backdrop of what was then a
major warsaw between the soviet union in
the united states over the stationing of
intermediate nuclear missiles in europe
the russians or the soviets were doing
uh missile stationing so was the united
states it was kind of you know basically
a lot of
grandstanding and maneuvering and in
1983 the soviet union actually misread
um u.s intent and we were on the verge
of a nuclear exchange i mean that's all
very clear now all the documents
declassified
you know even without knowing any of
that when i was you know at that stage
in high school it was evident that there
was such um international tension
and i resolved to go off and strike to
study russian they encouragement of
relatives and you know my family
thinking that i might become an
interpreter and maybe you know one point
perhaps you know i might be able to help
in some way
on arms control negotiations because you
know that was the the atmosphere of well
we were just going to blow blow
ourselves up
and i entered later into the
administration against the backdrop of
the russian efforts to subvert our
elections this sophisticated influence
operation that they launched in 2016 to
basically turn our electoral system the
presidential campaign and our politics
on the head and of course they succeeded
to a large extent
but i came out to the other side of the
time in the administration
and the government at the highest levels
they're seeing everything that i was
seeing including on russia much more
concerned about the united states
and in russia in the 1990s there was a
similar polarization of politics
the um collapse of the soviet union led
to millions of people losing their jobs
overnight and um with very little
prospect of
a life ahead because the whole state had
collapsed
and at the end of a decade of crisis
economic and political crisis
vladimir putin came in as president
saying that he was going to fix
everything put everything back to rights
but of course we've seen over the last
20 years
that putin has entrenched himself in the
kremlin he rolled back a lot of the
democratic gains that had been made
after the collapse of the soviet union
in russia
and he gradually kept on amending the
russian constitution so that essentially
he can stay in power now until 2036 by
which time he will have been in office
for a full 36 years he'll be in his 80s
and he'll have been the longest serving
leader in russian modern history
and the way that he did that there are
all kinds of hallmarks of developments
that are happening here in the united
states right now
and our polarization
is really acute and in fact i was just
observing that you've given out three
different telephone numbers for people
who identify themselves politically
now i would fall in that independent
category but the number one
identification in the united states
today as your numbers are suggesting is
either you a democrat or a republican
and i'm really worried that people have
lost the sense of themselves as
americans
and vladimir putin in russia
basically governs without any kind of
political party he actually
um you know strangely from our
perspective tries to unify the country
he does go after small groups of
russians who he sees having no larger
political base
but he tries to unify the country to get
over these kinds of divisions because
those divisions were what precipitated
the collapse of the russian empire and
then the collapse of the soviet union
political divisions ethnic divisions all
kinds of other divisions
but abroad what putin tries to exploit
is divisions in other countries and in
2016 we saw russian operatives on
facebook and other
internet platforms pretending to be
republicans pretending to be democrats
rarely pretending to be independent it
has to be said pretending to be
americans who were either pro-life or um
you know kind of basically
you know uh
let's say you know racist or not racist
or you know you name it i mean gun uh
programs anti-guns every side of every
argument that is very sensitive in the
united states trying to stir things up
and pit ourselves against each other
and you know this is um
a real dilemma that we have these
divisions that are encapsulated even in
you know the people who are going to
call in today these are the kinds of
things that can be exploited from the
outside and our polarization has become
a national security crisis
and as an american as a citizen as
someone who doesn't belong to a
political party as someone who came in
here you know 30 plus years ago in 1989
toward the end of the cold war
to come and find opportunity
just basically live a life like
everybody else's in america
i'm deeply disturbed by what's happening
and the parallels with russia with
modern russia and you know deans of
russian history and parallels with other
historical contexts that you know many
of the listeners today may be familiar
with are really startling and disturbing
and so one of the points of you know
writing this book
and explaining you know what i've seen
through a long um slave of time was to
try to you know get people's attention
so that people can actually see this you
know for themselves and take a long hard
look about what's happening i'll let you
chat with uh some of those listeners
those callers nikki a fellow independent
out of rockaway park new york up first
good morning you're on with fiona hill
if you wanna heal first of all i would
thank you for your courage and for your
willingness to be exposed to the threats
of people who like to hide the truth
rather than seek the truth
it is because of immigrants like
yourself and colonel vendeman
who refused to buckle down
under
and when they saw something going wrong
in this nation decided that it was a
patriotic duty to speak out you have
been vilified anyone who who wants to
hide the truth
has attacked people like you so first of
all i thank you for your courage how
would you compare the atmosphere in
america today to the atmosphere in
germany
pre-world war ii
well you know that's also another very
chilling um comparison and you know um
it's always
a risky comparison to make because of
course people then immediately think can
jump from you know the discussions of
what was happening in germany in the
1930s to the holocaust and you know the
horrors of world war ii you know which
seem very far fetched from what's
happening right now in the united states
but that early origins um of you know
the evolution of an autocratic
authoritarian state in germany in the
1930s there were an awful lot of
parallels because it involved the
perpetration of a big lie about what was
happening in elections there was an
awful lot of uh the german hierarchy big
business and the political class who
supported you know the rise of adolf
hitler thinking that they could
manipulate him and use him and that
nothing you know really um
drastic was going to happen that you
know this guy would basically look out
for their various interests and there
was also an awful lot of people who
supported him as a charismatic
individual and would not take any kind
of criticism or any warnings about what
was happening because they were
projecting all of their hopes and their
you know you know basically
aspirations onto this one person you
know right now we're in that danger zone
where we have a charismatic leader who
people kind of see as really their
avatar as their kind of person
representative they can't bow any
criticism about him they react you know
with um anger at those who
basically push back
and you know we're really in um as i've
said before a zone a danger zone in our
politics in our democratic system
that we have seen in many other settings
you know let's put aside some of the the
details and you know some of the
atrocities and other things that kind of
happened out of some of these settings
that you know not so likely here but the
danger to our democracy is very similar
and is very real
and there you know are so many things
that you know i would um recommend to um
listeners to go out and read about the
early 1930s in germany where people will
see you know if they come to it with an
objective mind the parallels it's why
you know i also raised what happened in
russia in the 1990s because although
russia's obviously a very different um
system
it also has um obviously a very
different history but there's always a
preponderance in russian political
culture to look out there for a strong
man well strong woman they've had
empresses you know in the past
and the united states our presidency
over time has started to emphasize the
strongman the very powerful executive
which is not the fundament of the united
states at all i mean the whole preamble
to the us constitution is we the people
there are 330 million of us and this is
an anomaly for the united states to be
so obsessed about
a presidential leader a presidential
figure and to be eroding the other
checks and balances in our system
our party system has started to all feed
up into uh this emphasis on a very
strong executive and on the person um of
the executive of the president again
something that is
contrary to american political culture
and american politics don's next out of
shreve ohio that line for republicans
good morning
good morning
yeah i wanted to talk about about the
economy
and you know what she went through then
compared to what we have now
that
they want to up the debt level
and all they talk about is not paying
the bills lying to us
we want to know why they won't talk
about
the country was broke in january
and they came up and let the immigrants
come across and invited them when the
countries broke and now they borrow the
money everything we do we borrow like
105 million dollars to help take care of
the immigrants and stuff
and give money away
and we've got people
on the streets living on the streets
there's always more money to give away
to other countries than there is to take
care of our own people
if you want to help well look i think
this is the the critical debate that's
happening um in congress right now about
the infrastructure bill and the
reconciliation bill which is how to
balance um all of this off
and obviously we've been debating you
know for quite some time you know the
whole future of foreign assistance and
then how we start to think about our own
internal uh development and you know the
um the caller
don has really you know put his finger
on that big debate that we've all been
grappling with about how to you know
start to redevelop america itself and
that's the crux um of um you know many
of the issues that i've actually
outlined in the book
because you know we're already seeing a
skewed
uh socio-economic situation one of
inequality
and um you know basically uh unfairness
in the united states places like ohio
michigan pennsylvania
uh the old industrial regions of the
united states being left behind in the
development of the new economy the
problem is it's extraordinary complex to
fix it's not just a question of
tinkering with the budget or you know
thinking about larger stimulus funds
it's actually a big development exercise
it's rooted in education and figuring
out how to give people access to getting
qualifications and new skills for the
new economy it's rooted in public
private partnerships you know to find
out how to train a new workforce for the
21st century it's rooted in community
neighborhood
local and state government uh politics
and decision making again it's not all
going to happen on the federal
government we have to bring back
responsibility and some of the ideas
for development back to the localities
and in places like ohio pennsylvania you
know michigan you know there are
actually some really good examples of
things that people can do to address
these questions without necessarily you
know adding uh to the larger federal
debt versions i've burdens i've you know
seen a lot
of really great work being done by local
development and regional development uh
councils i talk about some of these um
in the course of the book that you know
we really should be looking at i mean
it's really an investment in people's
communities and in their states and
regional
uh governments that and development that
we really have to focus on so
what's happening on the national level
is very important to getting that worked
out but it's really bringing things back
to our localities which is vital as well
we'll stay in the great lakes area this
is tom in illinois next good morning
yes hello thank you for taking my call
i was uh listening to the lady fiona
hill right now
and she was comparing hitler to donald
trump i guess you know
and uh so my question is tour
since the
durham report came out and it and it's
pretty much come out he's got one person
that he's indicted
uh that the whole russia russia russia
thing is totally false he had he was
inundated the whole time
through his uh presidential time as uh
being an evil dictator doing all this
terrible stuff
when when he himself said
that he had so many things against him
people bringing up uh
impeachment and all the stuff
uh
that
i i couldn't even imagine it myself
because i've been in a little bit of
government and government can really
bring stuff against you which is really
really uh
that's where you get into hitler's stuff
if you want to help give you a chance to
respond
yeah look and i think tom uh raises some
very important uh issues there because
you know what what you know i'm
describing
in response to the you know the original
question was really about charismatic
personalities and i said let's put aside
you know the the some of the larger
issues that happened in germany after
that initial point of the 1930s of you
know the kind of the rise of
you know the national socialist party
but you know what tom raises about the
russia uh case and you know the mueller
investigation i've actually addressed
you know myself on many other occasions
including during the testimony um at the
first impeachment trial and also i hope
tom you might read the book because i
actually lay out
some of the issues that you're raising
here the russians attacked our
democratic system
they wanted to cast a shadow over
anybody who would be president
they wanted to weaken uh people's faith
in our electoral system which you know
they
did a good job of
but they also provoked off um a massive
political reaction in the united states
which i think they're extremely proud of
because it was u.s actors that basically
as you said accused president trump of
being elected not by uh voters in the
united states which he was but by the
russians by the russian security
services and called him illegitimate and
that created a massive political crisis
my personal view is that the
investigations that were sparked off
initially around the russian
intervention should have looked at what
they were doing across the board they
shouldn't have started with one
individual campaign because i know that
the russians were also looking to try to
infiltrate the campaigns of many of the
principal
uh players that they thought were likely
to become the president they wanted to
basically cast a shadow over every
single one of them
uh they were definitely had hillary
clinton in their crosshairs they wanted
to they thought she was going to win and
they wanted to weaken her they also were
trying to again as i said target others
and then it was very true that that then
triggered off just in a massive domestic
political crisis here where all of our
politics were tainted by that influence
operation and we did not handle it well
we did not handle it well and again as
i've spoken out on these occasions
before
is that many people just played into
exactly what the russians wanted which
was questioning the legitimacy of the
person who became president
so
it wasn't that the russians didn't
interfere they did interfere but what
happened next is we played into exactly
what they wanted to do which was rip
ourselves apart
over that influence operation and i said
that you know very clearly at the
testimony when i was kind of calling out
uh what was actually happening around
that so we did need a thorough
investigation we didn't necessarily have
one we need to have still a very clear
reckoning about what happened
and we played into the hands of russian
operatives who wanted us to sort of
question the legitimacy of our system
the outcome of elections
and whether you know our president uh
was actually legitimately elected so i'm
afraid you know tom's right that there
was an awful lot of playing into an
influence operation and doing exactly
what the russians wanted us to do on
influence operations you've talked about
how vladimir putin has tried to exploit
other countries you talk in the book
about how vladimir putin tried to
exploit donald trump specifically use
his his kgb
training to influence donald trump can
you talk about that and also how you
believe
donald trump viewed vladimir putin
well both of these two things are tied
together because it was obvious to me
you know in my time working with trump
that trump really admired putin it
wasn't about russia but it was about
putin personally and the kind of leader
he was
uh president trump you know said all the
time i mean for him you know putin was
really the ultimate strong man um he
admired him he said it you know to close
associates um he admired the power that
he exerted he admired the role that he
played on the international stage
because everybody knows who putin is
everyone you know respects and fears him
somewhat and you know he's got unchecked
power at least from you know kind of the
outside that's what it seems inside of
russia it's never you know quite as
simple as that but certainly he doesn't
rule through a party he doesn't real
through parliament
he it's just him and the people in the
russian constitution that underpins his
uh his influence and um you know his
his position there
and putin of course struts uh across the
world stage you know cutting a rather um
you know impressive figure uh from the
outside so you know trump really admired
putin for what he thought that putin was
and that then tied into how putin was
able to manipulate president trump
because look no matter what you um feel
about trump personally i mean he's a
very casual asthmatic individual you
know i described in the book about you
know what his appeal is
he is also an incredibly thin-skinned
person and someone who's quick to take
insults and to then you know respond to
that and he's also very susceptible to
flattery anybody who follows him on
twitter could be retweeted by the
president if they said something nice
about him and world leaders you know
basically clued into the same thing so
president putin didn't try to blackmail
him as was suggested you know kind of
right at the onset of his presidency by
many that said he was putin's candidate
he was doing something for putin he
wasn't
but he was extraordinarily susceptible
very vulnerable to outside influence by
people who tried to you know basically
praise him and i saw um up front um that
you know putin for example would try to
manipulate uh trump i saw it in meetings
with him where he tried to push his
buttons and you know try to you know
push his commentary in a certain way
but also putin would say things on
russian national television for example
praising uh the economic performance
praising the stock market when he knew
that you know trump was very focused on
this
and in one occasion you know for example
president trump asked to have a phone
call with putin which is exactly what
putin wanted by basically saying well he
said nice things about me i want to call
him to thank him so there was just that
you know kind of very evident
manipulation that putin engaged in and
you know for me of course and others
watching this it was extraordinary
problematic because president trump
could be induced to do things purely on
the basis of someone flattering him
usually on national television
brooklyn new york this is alan line for
democrats good morning
good morning thanks for taking my call
and it's an honor to speak with miss
hill
um i'm just wondering from your
perspective both as a
student of history in a russian culture
and of politics
how do you see the role of evangelical
belief
fitting into the paradigm of trump
playing the strong man i recall
specifically interviews with scalia
before he died
where he talked about the likelihood
that the will of god is more likely to
be manifest in a country
when it is led as a monarchy rather than
a democracy as if they were almost
favoring changes in law that would
make a monarchic uh
power more likely to emerge
which seems totally contrary to the
american constitutional democratic
tradition i'm just wondering if you see
any of those strains and how could we
address them without seeming to invite
backlash or bigotry or threats of or
accusations of bigotry but just talking
about the dynamics of it in an objective
way
well look i think this is a really
important question and it's very
important to talk about it an objective
way as well because you know we
all have to respect uh people's faith
and you know the different
manifestations of that faith but as
you're saying in the united states the
tradition has been really to keep church
and state separate even though the
united states is very clearly founded on
uh judea christian uh principles and of
course you know in the previous segment
there was a caller you know talking
about the the puritans the pilgrims you
know first coming to the united states
and obviously wanting to be able to
worship as they had uh chosen having
been ostracized and persecuted in the
united kingdom
um and you know that there's a long
tradition obviously of people of all
faiths and all kinds of backgrounds
coming to the united states because the
united
uh to all states
the the zone that we get into that is
more complicated and more difficult is
when you know one religious um strand
starts to bleed into politics
and look in the case of russia vladimir
putin has actually embraced the russian
orthodox church as the russian czars had
be before him i mean obviously the
communist party did not they turned
atheism into a state religion and they
did actually kind of create their own
sort of charismatic person personality
cults around you know the um
the uh
secretary-generals of the the communist
party particularly stalin you know for
example who kind of created in himself a
kind of a
sort of state religion around his person
and interestingly stalin was from a
seminary he had actually been training
to be an orthodox uh priest so he
understood you know how to kind of play
with religion and uh religious faith but
you know kind of give it a more secular
hint
but what putin does is he embraces the
russian orthodox church and he kind of
gets the support of the church behind
him where you know a lot of people would
be a bit skeptical of that given you
know his um
rise through the corridors of the kgb
during the soviet uh period he makes a
big point of talking about his faith and
blending
religion in with the um the state and
russian orthodox
uh adherents are about eighty percent of
uh the russian federation which you know
again gives him a much larger base to
appeal to and of course we're starting
to see that in uh united states politics
you know um president trump has been
anointed as it were in many respects as
a kind of charismatic uh personality is
also a carrier and a bearer of religion
even though many people would say that
he's a flawed bearer of religion we've
um you know seen many times about you
know the prayer breakfast and all of uh
the you know various meetings in the
white house about how there's been
something of a fusion of religion with
politics and
people talking about
uh the president in religious terms
conversely how president biden has found
himself you know in a very uncomfortable
position
of clashing with um the catholic church
and with certain um catholic leaders
because of his uh position on you know
abortion rights for example so we do see
this at all times in the united states
we've always skirted a fine line
between
religion
and politics but again you know the
important thing is to have a debate
about this because the united states is
a country of many religious beliefs
of many uh denominations we always have
been you know since uh the very
beginning of the establishment uh of the
united states itself i mean there were
many faiths and many different
denominations within
uh the uh the founding fathers
themselves they weren't all from you
know one particular religious persuasion
and you know we have to remember that
and but i do think that having that kind
of discussion
is an important uh point i mean i was
brought up in the north of england
in a region where
the churches
of many denominations played a very
important role i mean i grew up in a
family where i had quakers
baptists presbyterians and methodists in
my family and many of my family also
married catholics and so religion and
religious faith was always a part of the
debate um and my family my mother
volunteered for years until she
physically wasn't able to anymore at a
non-denominational protestant church
that also was a community um
service provider and you know
faith-based institutions play a very
important role in our communities as
well so again this is part of the
discussion that we really do need to
have just about 20 minutes left in this
discussion this morning plenty of
callers waiting to chat with you this is
alan in wells maine independent good
morning
uh good morning thank you very much for
c-span uh
fiona i i love the title of your book
and i love that you're talking about
strongmen
and
and empires um
and uh
my my
alternative to your to the title of or
or
aspect to your to the title of your book
would be
there's nothing here for you to see
uh i often use that uh when i talk about
an empire and that a cop on the beat
typically says nothing here to see
walk along folks
but
in the case of empire the unique aspect
of our empire in my humble opinion being
a student of empire
the unique aspect of our empire is that
it is a disguised global crony
capitalist empire
and instead of a single
notable strongman like hitler or putin
or any of the people who are empire
thinkers
and
a ascribed to being an
emperor themselves like trump does
clearly he's a faux emperor but beyond
uh real emperors uh what we have here in
the united states again in my humble
opinion
we learned on hitler's dime
hitler and gobel's dime
when they entered
france in june of 40
they pulled the russian trade the german
troops back nazi troops back and tried
to fool the frenchman that oh you've got
a vichy government uh it's still your
government and they had john dom's on
the streets to try and fool the people
french the frenchman were too smart for
that
well we'll pause there and let fiona
hill jump in
well look i think alan's point about
crony capitalism and you know sort of an
empire of money you know in many
respects that he's describing
is a very valid one and you know
american politics has really changed in
the time you know since i came to the us
in 1989 and a large part of this is
because of the citizens united case that
was you know basically heard uh in front
of the supreme court
in which money and
big money was correlated with free
speech opening up the way for the
development of super political action
committee super pacs
in which you know um millionaires
billionaires and you know other uh
representatives of big business or of
you know generational money could
basically start to influence uh politics
by supporting candidates you know from
the local and state and uh national
level you know all the way across the
board for um
uh basically running for office but
without any real accountability
and you know allen is absolutely right i
mean we're dealing with a situation now
where you know most americans have
absolutely no idea of who is standing
behind various candidates or standing
behind various policies
and this is just a matter of fact
and you know the the best um
political campaigns have been run have
been basically run at the grassroots
with small donors people like listening
to c-span who are running local
candidates but at the national level so
many of our political
uh candidates for congress and the
senate or you know large officials are
running on the back of um big money that
really is trying to influence their
views and we've also got the results
from
investigative journalists independent
journalists who have just revealed this
information on the pandora papers i
don't know if everyone listening to this
has been able to see this you know kind
of across the country which is really
revealed about how many of our own
states south dakota was a bit of a
surprise to me as well even though i
know a lot about this you know being the
home for
so many shell companies of people hiding
money from around the world in the
united states it's not just the
seychelles the cayman islands
you know places that people normally
associate with shady money being stashed
away but it's here in our own united
states that kleptocrats from around the
world including from around the united
states are hiding money not just so they
can't pay taxes but so they can also use
this for influence by buying property or
buying politicians in our own country
down to oklahoma this is coleman line
for republicans good morning
hey good morning uh
democrats continue to want to focus on
trump in the canard of uh
he was an agent of russia and influenced
by russia while it totally ignoring
hunter biden receiving
three million dollars from
the mayor's wife of moscow
and
just like the
clinton foundation on the uranium one
deal
received
millions uh
to allow russia to
get a about 20 percent of the us's
uranium supply
uh all of the discussions
uh continue to uh oh
trump was a russian agent
and the ridiculousness of of all the
games that were played there
while ignoring actual
uh problems of the democrats
in in their collusions
with russia i'd like fiona hill let you
address some of those
look this is also another important
point about the way this whole issue was
handled that i you know mentioned a
little earlier and also you know caller
clint's just um
touched on the you know the very problem
that um i was just outlining in this
question
about um the way that you know big money
um has been able to enter the united
states from other places not just from
you know us um
millionaires and billionaires but also
from russian
um you know saudi you know you name it
uh basically coming in and sort of
perverting our politics and you know
into some of our uh most important
institutions
so i just would like to say though that
this is not a partisan issue this is
across the board and that's you know
what worries me about the framing of you
know much of our discussion um not just
you know here today on the washington
journal with you know the phone lines
coming in from democrats republicans and
the poor rest of us who are independents
and uh you know not quite sure how we
should be navigating during these you
know kind of positions that are being
set out by red and blue america as if
we're not one america here
and these problems that each of the
callers are describing are problems that
are across the board they're common to
all of us
this dirty money that's coming in trying
to influence our politics
through super pacs or through
foundations um or through putting you
know the children of all our politicians
on the books of different uh companies
that should be outlined across the board
outlawed across the board
it's not just a problem of democrats or
republicans it's a prom it's a problem
across the board for everyone here that
you know the children of key officials
should not be on the boards of foreign
companies they shouldn't even be i think
on the boards of united states companies
without proper scrutiny of all of this
because this nepotism this cronyism is
really perverting the course of the
united states politics at this point and
we should be having a national
discussion about this and it's been shut
down by special interests who basically
are paying for politicians to stop a
discussion about this which is you know
why many of us you know different levels
of society like through these kinds of
discussions that we're having now should
be mobilizing and asking you know our
local state and uh uh governments and
also our congress men and women but why
is this happening i mean this should be
disturbing for all of us and again it's
not a political party issue it's a party
it's an issue across the board in
american politics not just one side or
the other to share in pennsylvania this
is celeste good morning
good morning yes i'd like to agree with
the things she said about uh
the autocratic autocracy i watched um
apocalypse hitler last night and i'm
telling you it's like he took that and
made it his handbook
the
actions that trump
did the whole way through trying to be
the autocrat that he wants to be if you
watch those two shows last night
it is him to a t everyone should wake up
and see what's going on we talk about it
i heard it last night on cnn things are
changing in our world and somebody
better step up to the plate
and pay attention to what's really going
on he's a dangerous man
watch hitler and you'll find out thank
you very much
fiona hill did you want to jump in
yeah look i mean i think that you know
part of our problem is that as soon as
um you know somebody um from the past um
you know obviously with such terrible
connotations
is mentioned
you know then people immediately shut
down say oh okay right i don't want to
hear this anymore but you know if we
start to really look in an objective
fashion about what's happening
and i think it's more self-evident
for people like myself who have come in
uh to the united states who didn't
necessarily grow up here or came in from
other societies that have been
you know wrenched and torn apart by
civil conflict
you think about um all of the immigrants
who have come over the last 20 you know
30 years from you know conflicts around
the world who have come from europe
where there's been a long history of
violence and where europe has gone
through two wars in world war one and
world war ii and everyone in their
family knows someone who fought there
and you know we relied on the united
states for saving the day both in world
war one and world war two if it hadn't
been for the u.s and u.s troops coming
in and for their bravery you know europe
would uh uh i mean god knows what europe
would be like uh today but we all know
that history we internalize it we learn
from it and we're now seeing similar
things unfold here in the united states
and people like myself are trying to
stand up there and saying hey look i
know this is very uncomfortable you
don't want to admit that this is
happening but this is where we are the
united states is on a very dangerous
path apart that it hasn't been on uh
before we've had plenty of turmoil in
our long history the united states isn't
that new a country i mean the united
states throwing off you know the
monarchy of and the tyranny of britain
you know at the end of the 18th century
was the same time with the revolutions
across europe trying to you know
basically uh cast off emperors and
empires and kings you know the french
revolution you know for example everyone
was looking for a better life in which
we the people would be able to play more
of a a full role in our societies and
we're throwing that away right now we're
basically enthralled to political
parties that don't necessarily have our
interests in mind and are not not making
changes for us in the way that we're
hoping
and we're in real danger of putting all
of our you know kind of features in the
hands of one person
which is you know the reason we had a
revolution in the first instance
and you know i'm basically uh hoping
that people will take a long hard look
about what's happening just you know
cast aside you know all of the
ideas of who you are
and just think about you know the united
states and who we want to be and you
know the feature that we want for you
know our children
and you know for ourselves here and is
this the way to get it by you know
basically focusing on one person and who
is that person in the white house when
we've got a lot of capacity to do things
ourselves
in our local communities
in our states
you know there's a lot of prospect that
you know we have for ourselves for being
agents of change it's actually one of
the points that i make in the book
just about 10 minutes left in our
program this morning you mentioned
families a minute ago the dedication in
your book is for alf and june explain
who alpha and june are and what they
what viewers need to understand about
them to understand you
i'm often due to my parents um my dad
was a coal miner who like many people in
the united states you know didn't manage
to get a
full education he left to go down the
mines at the age of 14
following his father his brother
his grandfather all of his uncles and
great uncles and you know great
grandfather
you know you name it and you know there
was never really any other opportunities
for my dad um the mines actually and
when he joined um
uh the coal mines in um that period in
the late 1940s and then in the 1950s
was kind of a a great opportunity for
him because there was good wages to be
made the communities around the mines
were very vibrant in the 60s they all
started to close down and my dad
actually wanted to emigrate to the
united states of that period because
coal mines in ohio pennsylvania and west
virginia were recruiting for miners from
county durham which is where you know i
grew up
and my dad really seriously constant uh
considered moving to pennsylvania to the
lehigh valley
um but my grandparents were ailing at
this point and they couldn't go with him
and so he stared to look after his
parents like many people make that
choice to do in the united states
my mother um on the other hand i mean
she also left school at 16 uh older than
my dad but she went immediately to train
to be a nurse and became a midwife
and had you know actually a career that
she enjoyed very much in delivering
hundreds of babies
until um you know me my sister came
along and she had to leave work like
many women have to you know basically to
uh to look after us because it wasn't
very many child care options
but my parents
you know basically
instilled in me a very strong sense of
public service and social responsibility
because the communities in which we
grew up were very tight-knit
multi-generational all in the same place
my mother delivered pretty much every
kid
i grew up with and you know many more
besides everyone knew my mom um you know
because she delivered their babies and
she was also a different point to kind
of a a school nurse and sort of helping
out in the community as a kind of
community health visitor
and there was also a strong sense of
everybody pulling in together and
helping everyone out but as i said my
dad's dream had always been to come to
the united states i fulfilled that you
know much later on in whereas perhaps
that he never anticipated
but i brought with me that very strong
work ethos that um desire to get ahead
and also that desire to be part of a
larger community and to help out my
parents were not political people but
they were people who are very much
committed to the people around them
matthew's next out of alabama
independent good morning thanks for
waiting
hello yes thank you sir um yeah i'm
calling about the debt ceiling and an
economic cycle i don't understand why
americans think that we use chinese
money
or we use european money and now we got
to owe them money
because we're borrowing their money
which is not it at all
so i'm going to let you know about an
economic cycle you print out a dollar
you circle it around the world
eventually it's got to come back to
america through taxes
and the cycle continues
and that's about all i got to say thank
you for your help the economic cycle
that we're in
yeah um um we're um as the caller
suggests in you know another of these uh
cycles of change uh within the economy
um we've got fiscal pressures that we're
all seeing covet i mean we haven't
really mentioned uh the pandemic at all
in the course of uh this program this
has had a huge blow uh to our economy as
well as to the global economy and things
are changing as we see we have energy
crisis and shortages we have uh supply
and distribution networks that have
broken down
we're on the cusp now of a whole new era
in our economy and i think that this is
a time for reflection because it is a
time where we could be you know thinking
about how we focus on our own future
development what we do at home
you know to generate uh changes in the
economy that we would own that would not
be you know just about um investment
from overseas which no doubt will remain
important but how we build up our own
states and uh local economies so as the
caller is suggesting we're on the cusp
of a major change this is an inflection
point and i think a time for discussion
about how we want to structure our
economy moving forward
lanita fort i'm sorry ashley in candler
north carolina go ahead
thanks for taking my call good morning i
would just like to start out by saying
that
the most important thing that we have
in our nation currently right now is the
fact that it's october 12th
and we still have military men and women
left over in afghanistan
that joe biden has blood on his hands
and also i'd like to throw out one more
thing to say that
i am
applauding southwest
airlines
for the stance that their pilots have
taken against the mandates it has
nothing to do with weather this is
americans standing up and saying it's my
body my choice outside of abortion we
determine what health risk we're willing
to take and willing to accept
and my final thought let's go brandon
thank you
that's ashley in north carolina fiona
hill vaccine mandates or afghanistan
which you want to take up
well look both of these issues are you
know
current in our national conversation
that we need to be having i mean we have
to be able to listen to
um on uh you know the public health
issues um
as many discussions you know as we we
can to engage in here to figure out how
we get on top of this pandemic look i
come from a family
in which public health was uppermost my
father when he lost his job in the mines
and then couldn't find a job in the
local steelworks the brickworks and all
the other factories ended up working in
a hospital
my family experienced at firsthand the
scourge of infectious disease
i look like many people in america and
perhaps you know people can't touch back
to that period
um in their lives but the
generations of my family were either
extended because my family was so poor
that they waited a long time to have
children
and you know my great my grandparents
born in the late 1890s my grandfather
fought all the way through world war one
from the beginning to the end
many people in my family died from the
influenza pandemic in 1918 like many
people here in america and they talked
about it i mean i knew them i heard them
talk about it
my family were
um you know basically infected with
diseases that led to could be treated
with vaccines and they were first in
line to get the vaccines because they
saw with their own eyes and experienced
in themselves my mother lost part of her
hearing from measles before the
development of the measles vaccine
members of my family were stricken by
polio and they went out uh later to get
the polio vaccine we're always having
these debates about this
i mean basically my family made their
decision and public health wasn't
politicized in the same way that it has
been here in the united states
they wanted to live they wanted to
thrive they wanted their families to be
healthy and for them
vaccines their development was a miracle
it was a breakthrough it meant that
members of their family didn't die from
diseases that otherwise would have been
preventable i think we need to be having
that kind of debate there are a lot of
people like myself have come into the
united states and see getting vaccinated
and having these breakthroughs in
medicine as a privilege as something
that's turned away the scourge of
disease and death that our own families
experienced
i mean i'm someone who goes out you know
whenever there's an opportunity to have
a vaccine to have a vaccine because i
grew up in an environment where that was
a question of life or death for you and
the community around you and for your
family and on the issues of afghanistan
you know of course we've been in these
forever wars as they've been termed
since 9 11 i personally don't believe
that we should have gone into
afghanistan or iraq in the first
instance
and you know but we have had to gonna
grapple with this how we get out of
these wars is also very important and we
need to be able to have a sensible
objective
discussion about you know the the all of
these issues that are so crucial you
know for the future of the country it's
the polarization the politicization of
these vital issues that makes it
difficult for us to extricate ourselves
from the predicament that we're in
two minutes here before we're expected
to take viewers uh to the supreme court
uh live oral arguments live audio of the
oral arguments in an abortion case out
of kentucky cameron
vs emw women's surgical center
that's where you'll be going in about
two minutes if you stay here on c-span
but in that time fiona hill
just wanted to ask you to look ahead and
and draw on your russia expertise uh
what do you think president biden should
be uh concerned about thinking about as
he deals with russia and specifically
vladimir putin in
the months and years to come here
well look what he has to be really
concerned about is actually the domestic
front
because as i've been saying throughout
all of this our domestic divisions are
what vladimir putin and others can
exploit
and there are still you know russian
operatives out there on the internet
pretending to be americans
there are you know massive ransomware
attacks targeting our hospitals and
critical infrastructure these are like
acts of terrorism not just criminality
for example and you know we're always
you know trying to head off this
confrontation uh with russia in the
foreign policy realm but really we've
been having a confrontation with them
and with other actors it's not just the
russians in our own
informational space
we create this information they you know
basically propagate that disinformation
further
the antidote to all of this is actually
the kind of things that we're doing here
on washington journal and that cspan and
other
media outlets do which is allow
americans to have proper
physical in real time discussions with
each other because we have to be very
very aware that whenever we're fighting
with other americans calling them names
you know we're calling them out for
difficult political positions
we're kind of pushing to the extremes
debates over
abortion
um you know having um
all of these conversations about what's
happening in the supreme court that
others will hone in on this and try to
use it so we have to have a sensible
conversation as we possibly can and i'm
really grateful for an opportunity to
have a discussion with you here today
too and we're grateful
for you to join us for that discussion
speaking of the supreme court they're
getting ready to get underway this
morning the book uh there's nothing for
you here finding opportunity in the 21st
century the author is fiona hill do
appreciate your time
no thanks so much thanks for chumps
and that's going to do it for us this
morning we'll be back here tomorrow at 7
00 a.m eastern 4 a.m pacific now take
you live to the supreme court